i'm sorry i got scared there's something
outside
what's up y'all it's me curly your
favorite your favorite
and today we're going to be talking
about a brand new thriller slash horror
film
fear of rain if you're into these sorts
of films you're gonna love it if you
like getting scared in the dark on your
couch by yourself
with a snack you're gonna love this
movie
all right so let's talk story the film
is about a young 16 year old named reign
who is dealing with schizophrenia
and also vivid and intense
hallucinations through a series of
events she ends up thinking that her
neighbor kidnapped a kid
which if you ask me i kind of believe it
because i have cd neighbors too that i'm
always creeping on
that's so creepy unfortunately the only
person that believes her is this
sweet boy named caleb from school who
reign isn't even sure exists
so you might be sitting there wondering
what's the difference between a horror
film
and a horror slash thriller film let's
get into it
so horror thriller films have to have
like
a psychological twist in fear of rain
our leading lady
doesn't really trust herself so we're
not sure if we should trust her either
and any good horror slash thriller is
gonna have some twists to it
don't worry i'm not gonna give any away
here because we don't believe in
spoilers but
just know that there are really good
twists in this one
like really good and horror slash
thriller has got to have that creep
factor
this movie has spooky settings creepy
characters
and plenty of jump scares
it's just my creepy neighbor and of
course no horror slash thriller film
is complete without a stellar cast so
let's dive in
our leading lady rayne is played by
madison iceman
at 23 years old she's already a
hollywood veteran and
she brings some serious acting chops to
what is a very complex character
i don't care what if it was me i'm not
just gonna sit here no way
her parents are played by harry connick
jr that man is so hot
and katherine heigl two hollywood
legends in their own right so you would
think that having both of them's parents
would be anything but intense but of
course
this is a horror slash thriller film so
not all is as it seems
your mind is just playing tricks on you
then there's caleb who's played by
another film veteran
israel broussard caleb is the only guy
at school
who treats rain like an actual person so
of course he's too good to be true
right no right i'm i'm asking
i just need you to trust me i do all
right
the film deals heavily with
schizophrenia a condition that the main
character reign is living with
the film's writer and director castille
london really put a lot of care
research and attention into creating the
main character reign
she sought out young people living with
schizophrenia and engaged with them
in order to learn how they navigate
through the world so that she could
create a multi-dimensional
and empowered character in fear of rain
you understand
the attention that was given to rain's
character because you recognize her
challenges
and you empathize with her so basically
if you're into horror thriller films
it's got a great cast
it's got great jump scares it's got
great scary music it's got like moments
where you could grab onto your boyfriend
and just love them
or if you don't have a boyfriend just
grab onto a pillow you're going to thank
me you're going to love it
it comes out any way that you can render
by a film on february 12th get it
watch it you're going to love it thank
me later i'll see you around let's watch
it together text me hit me up dm me
we'll watch it together